this is the Britain of the past as is
this and this our world is constantly
evolving from the clothes we wear to the
jobs we do and even how we interact with
each other but whether you grew up in
the 50s or the 60s or even the 80s an
exclusive poll for Sky News shows that
the majority of us fills nostalgia for
the Britain we grew up in to reveal the
results of our survey here are the
timeless trio so we asked people whether
they thought things were better now or
in the time they grew up in across a
range of topics
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
our results show that this sense have
been worse off now it's felt by people
of different political views and
generations like neighbours John and
Richard we've got 40 years between them
things have changed we had we had a row
of shots just from the corner didn't we
which which had a greengrocers
approaches bakers yeah MP they would
meet there and that people would meet
there it was nice if you go back to the
sixties with people like Richard in his
age group we were much much more
optimistic we were much much more
optimistic about what the future held
for us promising a return to the
traditions and values of the good old
days can be a powerful campaign card for
use in politics
but it can also be a dangerous one to
play if you're promising to take society
back to the conditions and the
structures and the power dynamics of the
past there are a lot of groups in
society who are probably going to lose
from that whether that's women or
minorities any group that has seen
social liberalism for example advance in
their favor we might not always remember
the past accurately but whether
nostalgia is for a past real or imagined
in both cases it's a powerful tool one
that can either inform the presence will
stop us moving forward
katarina vertices Sky News